[Musique]
la belle qui couchait avec le roi de
Prusse avec le roi de Prusse à qui l'on
attendu le crâne Razibus le crâne
Razibus son penchant prononcé pour les
ichli bedich pour les ichli Bich avec la
prononciation lui valut de porter
quelques cheveux postiches quelques
cheveux
postiches les braves sans culotte et les
ponets frigiens et les ponets
frigiens on livrer sa crinière un toneur
de chien un
toneur le
chien j'aurais dû prendre un peu parti
pour sa toison parti pour sa toison
j'aurais dû dire un mot pour sauver son
chignon pour sauver son
chignon mais je n'ai pas bougé du fond
de ma Tor peeur du fond de ma Tor peur
les coupeurs le cheveux en quatre m fait
peur en quatre m fait
peur quand pire qu'une brosse elle e été
tondu elle e
été
[Musique]
j'ai dit c'est malheureux ces accroches
cœur perdu ces accroche cœur
perdu et ramassant l'un d'eux qui
traînit dans l'ornière qui traînit dans
l'ornière je l'ai comme une fleur mise à
ma boutonnière mise à ma
[Musique]
boutonnière en me voyant partir arborant
mon Toupé arborant mon
toup tous ces coupeurs de Nat mont prix
pour un suspect monont prix pour un
suspect comme de la paderie je ne mérite
guerre je ne
mérite guerre pas comme toi j'ai pas la
croix d'honneur j'ai pas la croix de
guerre j'ai pas la croix de
guerre et je n'en souffre pas avec trop
de rigueur avec trop de
rigueur j'ai ma rosette à moi c'est un
accroche cœur c'est un accroche
je